[Music]
welcome back and get ready state leaders
say election night could look
more like an election week or even an
election
month and the controversy surrounding
the u.s postal service right now that is
only
one factor among many it will also take
time to deal with different state laws
and to simply open all the ballots that
are expected to be
mailed in plus leaders want to make sure
they get it right that's always
important
cbs news chief washington correspondent
major garrett joins us he's been looking
into all of this
major good morning you spoke to a
bipartisan group of
secretaries of state these are the
people in charge of elections at the
state level
also an election security official what
do they tell you about how they're
preparing
that this is going to take a while that
because the nation in some areas is
going through a rather large transition
from in-person to mail-in voting this
process will play out for a longer
period of time especially where counting
is concerned here's the good news though
states that have a long history of
voting by mail are giving all the advice
they can to states that are trying to
make this
transition and where the learning curve
is somewhat steep
they also tell us tony that the
president's rhetoric about rigging and
fraud does not help them
it confuses and sows doubts among voters
but they're working together
persistently trying to make sure this
election
is believable trusted for the losers
and the winners when new york city
voters cast primary ballots in june
few expected this would be the scene at
the board of elections
no declared winner one month later
president trump cried fraud
without evidence i think you should redo
that election
it has taken election officials some
time to do the counting
about 40 percent of new york state's
primary ballots arrived by mail
a nearly 11-fold increase over
pre-pandemic levels
now new york and other states are
scrambling to scale up mail-in voting
more ballots by mail means results could
be slower
and that means voters will need to be
patient absentee ballots or mail-in
ballots
tend to be more labor-intensive because
you have to
check the signature on the the envelope
to match it against the voter
registration record you need to
open the envelope separate out the
security envelope
then remove the voter's ballot kim wyman
is washington's republican secretary of
state
we want accuracy above everything so
it's going to take time
washington is among five states that
already vote almost exclusively by
mail this fall in an effort to keep
voters safe from coronavirus five
more states and washington d.c will
automatically send
mail-in ballots to all registered voters
well the problem with the mail in voting
number one you're never going to know
when the election's over
waiting it may be the hardest part but
this year it won't necessarily mean
something's gone wrong
we may not have official results for
quite some time chris krebs oversees
election cyber security
at the department of homeland security
certain states might not get called for
some time
and that's okay be prepared be patient
and most importantly participate in the
process
colorado is an all vote by mail state
where democrat jenna griswold
is the secretary of state it does take a
little longer to process mail ballots
and by the way they're more secure than
a lot of other forms of voting
one thing colorado does to speed things
up it processes mail-in balance before
election day
no results are reported until that night
but griswold says
there are other advantages increases
security
because russia cannot hack a mail ballot
and it's the best way to vote in social
distance
michigan wisconsin and pennsylvania are
all expecting large increases in mail-in
voting this year
and all three were pivotal to deciding
the outcome in 2016
but none allows for early processing of
mail-in ballots
the other states have already figured
this out so i'm hopeful we'll be able to
do so
come november jocelyn benson is
michigan's democratic secretary of state
she has sparred with the gop-controlled
legislature
on this issue not if the legislature
fails to act citizens not just in
michigan but around the country need to
know
exactly why it will take a little bit
longer perhaps even a few days longer to
get the full results out of michigan
again washington secretary of state kim
wyman half of the country believes joe
biden's going to win
half of the country believes president
trump's going to win and our job as
election officials is to inspire
confidence
in the losers so i know the big question
out there how long is it going to take
well if this election is close tony
secretary wyman said the results the
official results may not be known until
mid
to late november and as a part of that
we talked a lot of these secretaries of
state they say that among them there is
a prayer
let it be a landslide not just this
election but any election
yeah a lot of politicians are calling
for that as well two important points
that i think i would leave people with
first the number one reason a ballot is
rejected is not that it's late but
because people forget to sign the ballot
or they sign it differently than what's
on their license so sign it and take
your time doing it
second point is if you're not trusting
the postal service at this moment and
you know who could blame you uh
almost all states are supposed to allow
mail-in ballots to be hand-delivered at
local election offices so that's
something people can explore
in their local areas such an important
story major thank you very much